this video was made possible by better
help.com / Pakman where you can get
affordable online access to a licensed
therapist through text phone and video
chat
just click the link under this video
let's talk about trade Donald Trump has
been making massive claims about what he
says is this heroic replacement to NAFTA
the North American Free Trade Agreement
called u.s. MCA he did a big press
conference there was a huge hubbub
around it right-wing media got very very
involved in touting it as just this
incredibly masterful thing that Donald
Trump has pulled off and Donald Trump
has been calling it a brand new deal and
he's saying that on the basis of this
quote brand new deal he has delivered on
the campaign promise of getting rid of
NAFTA the North American Free Trade
Agreement Fox News made a huge deal
about this saying that Trump putting in
place the u.s. MCA is revolutionising
global trade so let's go what kind of
back to the beginning on this right
this entire NAFTA trade thing started
because during the campaign Trump
started making claims about the u.s.
being treated unfairly when it comes to
trade it was clear he didn't really know
much about trade and it was even more
clear that the people in his base who
fell for his expertise on trade also
didn't know much about it and Trump
ended up successfully bamboozling his
followers into thinking Trump knows
about trade trumps going to fix trade
we've got to get rid of NAFTA Trump
calling NAFTA the worst trade deal ever
and it worked people voted for Trump and
they believed that he would fix the
issue that he explained exists and now
we have a situation where Trump a--sort
of unilaterally and completely opposed
to NAFTA at a base level now I'll be the
first to admit I have no interest in in
sugarcoating the idea that NAFTA has
major major problems it's a trade
agreement involving the US Canada and
Mexico it has issues it's just not
as bad as Trump said and more
importantly solving the problems that
NAFTA has isn't as easy to do if you
want to avoid creating new problems in
that process and that's sort of the big
con here which is that Donald Trump is
now claiming not only that he has fixed
the issues of NAFTA but that he has
replaced NAFTA with the u.s. MCA that's
the big con the u.s. MCA is basically
NAFTA with some modifications it's like
NAFTA 2.0 NAFTA lite call it whatever
you want and some of the modifications
are important again I I want these
issues to be resolved and I have no
interest in merely saying everything
Trump does is bad some of the
modifications that Trump was able to do
are significant but they're not
revolutionary and it's certainly nothing
close to actually getting rid of NAFTA
it's coming up with a slightly modified
version of NAFTA and giving it a
different name which brands it
differently which is often what it what
actually achieves political success
which is just the branding of the things
that you do so let's talk about it what
does the US MCA actually do the biggest
change is labor provisions okay one of
the provisions in u.s. MCA is that by
2023
40 to 45 percent of automobile content
meaning the stuff that makes up the
finished car must be made by workers
earning at least 16 dollars an hour this
specifically targets Mexico in the
United States working in the auto body
I'm sorry auto manufacturing field for
16 dollars an hour is not that much of a
stretch in Mexico it is more of a
stretch because wages are lower so the
idea of mandating that by 2020 342 45%
of automobile content must be made by
workers earning 16 dollars an hour the
idea is number one shrink the gap the
wage gap between the US and Mexico so
that you will make it less appealing to
move production to Mexico and if you're
lucky create more
employment opportunities in the United
States now it happens to go directly
against free trade it's a form of
restricting the movement of labor but
we're used to that hypocrisy by now so
no real surprise there another provision
from the US MCA cars and trucks must
have 75% of components manufactured in
Mexico the u.s. or Canada in order to
qualify for no tariffs previously that
was sixty two point five percent of
components is that massively
life-altering the way Donald Trump is
claiming is it fair to say that NAFTA is
gone and we have something totally
different when all you've really done is
say well instead of sixty two point five
percent of components it's 75 percent of
components I think that most reasonable
people would understand that that's a
pretty big stretch when it comes to
saying that NAFTA is gone and something
completely different is here the idea is
get manufacturers to buy parts from our
three countries in the deal instead of
Asia that's fine but going from sixty
two point five percent to seventy five
percent is not exactly a blockbuster
deal that bears no resemblance to the
previous one that Trump said is the
worst deal ever in other words if NAFTA
was the worst deal ever with sixty two
point five percent of automobile
components needing to be required be
manufactured in these three countries to
avoid tariffs does making it seventy
five percent now make it a good deal or
is it just a slight change from what we
had before the u.s. MCA also adds some
provisions for the party countries to be
able to sanction each other for
violations of the agreement NAFTA didn't
have that so that is a difference the
problem is if you think back to TPP one
of the real horrible things about TPP
was that it created this sort of
transnational extrajudicial way of doing
arbitration when there are disagreements
or misdeeds by countries at the country
level the way that the u.s. MCA would
allow country
is that a party to the deal to sanction
each other is very similar it's one of
these transnational sort of multi-step
processes is that a good thing certainly
wasn't good when it was part of TPP so
yet again another one of these hypocrisy
and then lastly there's the dairy
industry Trump has been talking a lot
about the dairy issue for a while Canada
as part of the u.s. MCA is agreeing to
tweak its dairy market it's gonna get
rid of something called Class seven milk
which made it cheaper to buy certain
kinds of high protein milk products from
Kanak a Canada US farmers didn't like it
they wanted to sell their high-protein
milk to Canada this will help some
farmers in the United States but it's a
very small number it matters to them I'm
not saying it isn't important to them
but macro economically it is almost
completely insignificant and the idea
that again that makes this a drastically
different deal the NAFTA is pretty
laughable
and then lastly intellectual property
copyright is going to be extended from
50 years beyond the life of the author
to 70 years beyond the life of the
author including more protections for
some drugs from generic competition I
don't know if that's good I mean there
are problems in the world of copyright
but a lot of those problems are that
copyright is too strong rather than too
weak so the idea that you're going to
solve problems by making copyright even
more strict big picture in the net is is
very hard to believe for me so overall
this is being touted as this just
massive life-changing alteration to the
status quo of NAFTA
it's a tweak it's a tweak and Trump is
going to push it as a major success and
more than likely he will have some
success pushing it in that way it's not
the reality on the ground